As promised I came back with another video
explaining how i shoot the film profiles in
terms of exposure, temperature and color filter,
and how to install the creative luts to get
the same same look
I also made some updates to the film profiles
to give even more pleasing colors
Just finished the Eterna high fidelity profile.
a couple weeks ago i made a tweaked version
based on cine4 but now i will also release
the highfidelity simulatioon which is pretty
much 95% identical to the fuji eterna simulation,
so it will be much easier to color match the
2 or just get really nice colors out of the
sony.
and working on a new classic chrome and kodakchrome
64 profile from fuji so stay 'till the end
to find out more info about that
This video was shot on fuji400
Some profiles have been modified, and the
first one is vektro100
the only modification brought to this profile
is the decrease in the black point which was
lowered to -15 for even more contrast
Next on the list is the fuji400
I changed the Black level +3
Knee to 80% +1
and the biggest modification is the reduction
of the saturation to +5 which is not even
a modification itself, because the original
profile had +5 from the begining but i might
have had a typo when making the graphics for
the video, so sorry for that
next profile is portra 800
the initial portra800 was made for a candy
look but nowadays i'm using portra800 for
a variety of projects so i need a more natural
look.
First thing black gamma narrow +7
i brought down the saturation down
color phase to 0 or -2 depending on preferences
and in the color depth it's going to be
Red +3
Green +5
Blue +4
Cyan -4
Magenta -3
Yellow -3
Next profile that i've changed i kodak gold
Set the black level from -15 to -10 because
i felt it was maybe too contrasty
Black gamma wide -7
change the color mode from s-gamut3 to s-gamut
simple because i noticed how s-gamut3 was
shifting parts of the yellow spectrum towards
magenta and
s-gamut is overall more even with the yellows
which is exactly what i want.
These are the modifications that have been
made to the profiles.
Now let's see how to shoot the film profiles?
Initially, i made the film profiles for myself,
but they came out so good i had to share them
with the everybody else.
with that in mind, my style is darker, moody
with athypical color schemes, and some people
might say stuff like '' ohh your shots are
underexposed and the skin color isn't accurate"
this is my personal style, in commercial work
i shoot differently
but right now we are shooting artistically
so for a general guide, besides portra 800
which i overexpose by 1 or 2 stops,with the
rest of the profiles I usually underexpose
by one stop or even 2-3 stops and in the color
filter i go for a green cyanish look
not all profiles go with that so i will give
you general guides you can start with when
shooting each profile
Pp1 Vektor100
usually i like a green cyan look so i use
c3g1.5 nighttime i usually shoot 3900 or 4200
with a yellow filter giving it a super warm
look.
Pp2 Senova Light
usually lower kelvin and enhanced reds or
magentas so i shift it towards a3 or m3
Pp3Fuji400
this actually works well in both colder and
warmer tones, so go for cyan green look or
sometimes just lift up the kelvin by 500-1000
Pp4 classic chrome
this profile is still under development but
from what i've been experimenting is work
really well with warmer tones, so at the moment
i would shoot correct temperature or above
and bring the color filter towards red magenta
pp5 Evpro+
is a versatile profile, but usually i shoot
colder with this profile, so maybe try going
2000k bellow normal and add a green tint to
it
Pp6 Ektar100 usually colder tones, or hot
magentas, so shift the color filter towards
either cyan or red
Pp7 Portra 800again, a very versatile profile
with super soft gradations
will look good anyway you push it.
if you want to get a more warmer tone just
like in the movie 'Her' , shoot 500-1000 kelvin
above normal shift the filter towards magenta
to get a soft dreamy look
Pp8 Kodak gold
definitelly go hot, 1000 k-2000k higher than
normal and shift the color filter towards
magenta red
pp09 Eterna Simulation, High Fidelity
haven't tested too much with this profile
but you can try any of the above and let us
know in the comments if you find any interesting
settings
Pp10 i'm going nostalgic with this one, so
take it to magenta blue to accentuate the
natural earthy tones
You can also go into the extremes if you want
a more artistic look, definitely nothing wrong
with that, just try to feel the mood and what
colors the scene is asking for.
Guys, these are only suggestions, not golden
rules, and even rules are made to be broken,
otherwise nothing great would be created.
So try them out and experiment, because that
what this is about
Currently i am working on the classic chrome
and kodakchrome 64 profile, will be releasing
the settings for that soon, so subscribe and
hit the like button to see that video coming.
let me know in the comments what film stock
or film profiles you would like me to create
and maybe it's possible, who knows
It s wonderful how sony is giving us so much
control over the image with picture profiles,
and with so many options to choose from, but
still it feels like there is room for improvement.
It would be amazing if we could adjust individual
color hue and saturation
This way we could match different camera brands
and create more complex profile in camera
for any kind of situation
This would be the game changer for sony color.
So please sony do this, offer more control
in camera.
Besides the color filter you can use the creative
film luts to push things evem further, so
let's jump into davinci to see how it's done
so the basic theory behind Luts in general
are very limited in terms of information they
hold, they can only store Saturation Hue and
Luma Values, which means you cannot add any
effects like red halation and such
And once you put a lut over the image it's
like a permanent limitation, because
you cannot adjust the contrast or change the
colors of the lut sepparately
that's why i segmented the creative film luts
into Base Lut, Film Contrast, Classic Film
Color and red halation Effects for those who
work in Davinci Resolve
For those working in finalcut or premiere
pro separating the contrast from the color
you can actually have more control than any
classic lut which limits your control over
the image and kinda destroys it
The ones working in dainci can buy the powergrades
which actually gives full control over the
effects and can further inhance it in the
node panel
in Davinci resolve Install the luts by making
multiple Powergrade folders, import the files
into each folder separately.
add 4 new nodes by pressing Alt+S 3 times
and then just choose drag
and drop onto each node a different effect.
I usually go first node Base Lut
second node Film Contrast
third node Classic
Film Color
fourth node Red Halation
In premiere or
final cut you can do the same by applying
the luts onto different adjustment layers,
but unfortunately it doesn't include the halation
effects because, like i said earlier, the
LUTs contain limited information
In this pack i prepared over 30 different
contrast gammas and over 40 color schemes,
which results in more than 1000 possible unique
variations, pretty crazy ey?
Also snucked in the exact same luts i have
used in the original video for each profile
+1 extra one, this is for people that are
a little bit lazy and don't like to choose
heheh.
yeah, so have fun experimenting, and man you
have loads to experiment with.
like and share if you appreciate this video,
subscribe to see the classic chrome film recipe
coming upp and supoport the channel by buying
the creative luts or just buy me a coffee
Take care and see you next time